more than ten percent of Europeans admit
having bought goods or services
involving undeclared work to tackle the
problem MEP is voted in favor of a
European platform on undeclared work
composed of European Commission new
member states and its social partners
this platform should be a place for
exchanging views best practices so in
order to help different countries to
tackle their own problems more
efficiently the consequences of
undeclared worker serious dangerous
working conditions low earnings lack of
social security and huge losses for
national governments with a platform
labour inspectors would be trained to
implement legislation on undeclared work
when we talk about the undeclared work
we are talking about two kinds one is
undeclared work within a given land
mistake but then you have the very
serious problem of cross-border and
declared work and there is no way that
an individual member state either from
descending or from the receiving side
can tackle this problem without very
serious cooperation the next step is
negotiating an agreement in a try log
with the Commission and the council
to say